今日はアフ2冊をですと言う今日の動画
おばあちゃんがリンゴ落とし続けると切り日
ブーブーおりますよろしくお願いします
ブーブーんですかブーブーワック冥府
いいいいあっは何いますかなぁ
なんでちょっと協力していただきたいことがありまして人って物をよく落とすと思うん
ですよね
ものを落とすとある程度年齢優しい人だったら拾ってくれると思うんですよ
そんな全員に漬け込んで今日はおばあちゃんがリンゴを紙袋にたくさん入っててそれを
今から俺の後輩とか友達の目の前で落としてもらっ
で拾ってくれると思うんですけど優しいか拾ってくれるんですけど
おばあちゃんがありがとうねってこうのって言ったらまたあーバター茶飲んでまたあり
月ねー
バーってやるとみんなのちょっとさせに感がいいんで気づくような気がするんですよ何
回もやってるとも怪しいぞとこのおばあちゃんわざとやってるのかなとか
またまで動画の企画だなとか思って来カメラを合わせたようなそうなんですよ同大か
なっていうのは本当君なってたんで今日は実際にそれを件
そうしてみたいと思いでリンゴなんですけどとどうですかこれすごくですけど
めちゃくちゃリアルに下のりんごです
me
みんな変わりも人ですよねしない何か見たかったという理由でちょっとおばあちゃんに
は落としそうな感じを出して欲しいねちょっと今でしょうードゥン楽しんでてください
よろしくお願いします
えっ
便利の指導の方ちょっとここからさせていただきますじゃあ
5位場所
こんにちはー
rar
じゃっ菜園ぞ
ni イェイ盗んでもらえると思う
なきゃいけない大丈夫
好きで
フクロウした東方を持つと思う
ワークってますそれを剥いてくださいといけないじゃない
ん
ます
ああああああ
me
あああぁああ
完璧にさん情報で大丈夫
どうですかねこんな感じで
さあ10月止めましたおばあちゃんをよろしくお願いいたしませ紙袋しっかり持って
その紙袋の中には大量のりんごをもう一度おさらいしましょう
ターゲットとすれ違いざまにリンゴをぶちまけて大丈夫ですから大丈夫です勝って
ターゲットはきっと良いとなので手伝ってくれますこのはちゃん待っててねと言って品
をしっかり拾ってくれている間におばあちゃんも広いふりしてこそ
がいたいなぁとアピールをしつつ時間を稼いで行くその間にしっかりとキングを集めて
もらっておばあちゃんがもう1回リンゴをぶちまけますこれを繰り返すだけの簡単なお
仕事ですでは早速行きましょうまず一人目のターゲットですよろしくお願いします
さあやってまいりました最初のターゲットですときに何を言ったかことなく大家の前を
通るという指示のもと家の前を通るところおばあちゃんが現れました
サイバーアクション映画リングはデブつなげていきますもう風のごとくしっかりとお
ばあちゃんの物理てにおはっ
れるのを手伝ってあげておりますここまでは中で取りですね
ですよね母に多い量の日本入らせていただいております
つかまされた
さあさっそく偽物のリンゴに気付いたターゲットこれに特急と気づいたのでしょうか
さあほとんどのリンゴが開始勝負とところでおばあちゃんがもう一度リンゴのフクロウ
縁だけでちょっと雑貨月6敗で大丈夫かツアー払ってしまっております始め冊を
しっかりとうするから見させていただいております
吹っ飛んでしまったり後もしっかりと集めていきますさあ袋にもう一つ目終わった
ところでおばあちゃんが経ち
リンゴを手伝って持ち上げた貞子のしっかり仮想ブロックされ
ぬブロックもう落とさせないを通させないというブロック
通路から大丈夫心配しているご様子ですね
さあこれはをすぱっはぁまるでベースしてる
ステージてこれますけど試合みたいなっていうかうち海の音させないようなで揺れてる
しっかりとマークしております
ブーブーああ
さて指でそっと守りが薄くなったところしてくれたおばあちゃん落としていきますさ
大丈夫か
あそこ ed ベースですしっかりの衛生コースに入っています
まあ水は覚えておきましょうばあちゃんさあ後ろ
大丈夫かぁああ
ゴールではいけない後ろ向きでしまったまたお待ち箱を落としてしまいます
ごめんはばあさんこんが出てもう一度袋に人も爪を割って
さあどうするまた距離をとってしまう大丈夫でその時その時
りんごがりんごが飛んでしまうぞ大丈夫が
たじゃあ
なんであんたがおばあちゃんだよーぐっつかというと
またリンゴがしっかり集め終わっている東中でただ行っている
あああああっはぁ
なーん心得だ
もう朝倉に気づいてじゃないでしょうかもたなっちがボってますねもうフクロウ
しっかりと思っています
してい
pabo もうダメと言われてますね惚れやすいけれどばあちゃんのお家まで運んで
あげて行くスタイルができてしまっておりますねこれ
っていうのはまあ作成の中なんですけども僕おばあちゃん言ってそういうときは
フクロウを取り返してくださいってきっとおばあちゃん
なんかうまいことを言って話してフクロウ取り返してくれますああああああっ
っぽいが1個だけを取っちゃうんですねまぁ1個なら大丈夫ですね打つのバザーそんな
もんじゃありませんっああっフロス
8英語としていきますあっ広い畑のもうちょっと怪しいおおっとダメでね
危ないぞ本当に号地でしまったこれ逆方向にちょっと来い
おばあちゃんがリンゴ a に脅し続ける時でしたなぁ
さあ2人目のターゲットリセ次は誰が来てくれるのでしょうか
さあ単位のたてるんですねおばあちゃんとしっかりと対峙してすれ違います
ターゲットに sutter 会いに来てという指示を出しておりますおばあさんが
しっかりと一般人を装って近寄ります pot たクロック
いうか
岡大丈夫か
[音楽]
はい心配しております大事なことですねここでをバーズアイなそろそろ
ドロップ字体当たりはほぼ体当たりでリビングを落としていきます
ターゲットの自覚といったところでしょうか疾病と金を拾っております
はいしっかり集まりましたね
さあここでアームが入ってしまったビッツ柴田ケイコ散らばる結構連なる
[音楽]
何言ってんだよちゃんと日本語喋ってくださいさあまたしっかりとりんごを集めてくれ
ます
温めたことを教えてくだけどっ
あー小正感情が濃くて変な声が出てしまっております
[音楽]
例えば大丈夫か大丈夫かなんだよディフェイスやボディ明示するんですねみんなここ
まで来ると
青葉台
ああああああ
てしまったん
やってしまったーーー
部が優しいですねしっかりとまた拾ってくれます
あーだ漫画家てしまった集めている途中にも落としてしまう
[音楽]
その通りです本当に女に落とせるどこまでこれからなぁ
んです女されたさせたや自分じゃないですかねサーまた集め終わりました
さあ
このおばあちゃどうする鏡声がかかるとううわっ
た後麻生店じゃあおばあちゃん
[音楽]
eleanor